you are a member of the nasty party I'm
reading this morning
no that's not the case I mean the odds
that we've produced punched pretty hard
but they do so for an important reason
and that is that the government has a
record it's got a 13-year record we
talked about that record last week on
crime this week we'll be talking about
in terms of the cost of living and
mortgages and council tax rates and the
bills that people have to pay and the
underlying Point behind it all is we're
not going to accept
that British politics is just about a
new leader of the conservative party
every year or two who pretends that
everything before didn't exist and that
it's year zero that's not the case
politics can do better than that and
that's what these ads and her campaign
is all about yeah but you can't be
saying that the Prime Minister doesn't
want to jail child sex offenders
well they've got a record and for
example if you look at the record on
criminal prosecutions of sex offenses
compared to seven or eight years ago
those charge rates are about a quarter
of what they were then so the record
matters and we've got to increase these
charge rates and prosecution rates
because right now there are too many
crimes where someone committing the
crime commits it with the assumption
that they won't get caught and it's a
double
injury to the victim of crime because
not only are they a victim of the crime
but they also have little faith that the
person committing the crime will get
prosecuted so you stand 100 behind
adverts that we've seen where you've
suggested that the Prime Minister does
not want to jail sex offenders I stand
behind uh anything to answer anything I
do stand behind our campaign because
it's pointing out uh their record we've
got to do better and we can do better on
charge rates and prosecution rates
because we were doing better even seven
or eight years ago we were doing better
and we've now got to the point where far
too many people have lost faith in the
criminal justice system to bring those
who commit crimes to Justice we want to
change that and do something about it
and we also want to point out that
things are much worse now than they were
even seven or eight years ago what are
the no-go areas which areas are just
like just too far you even even the
front bench of the labor party will
think oh no we can't say that we were
pointing out the record uh I mean we've
done no no nothing's off the table well
I mean I don't want to put it like that
what I want to say is like but that's
what I'm asking you well last week we uh
pointed out the record on crime
particularly in relation to sexual
offenses this week we're focusing on the
economy the cost of living mortgages
council tax uh people's ability to pay
their bills and so on
these are legitimate areas for public
debate and the really important point I
come back to underlying it all is that
we are not going to accept a political
narrative that says every time the
tourists change the leader every year or
two the Slate is wiped clean and nothing
that went before counted this is a
conservative government and British
politics can do better than a new
iteration of a conservative government
every couple of years um
families are fair game are they
his family is fair game the prime
minister's family well we um uh you know
we point out for example I assume you're
referring to the non-dom situation uh
you must be Sherlock Holmes this is this
is a a tax loophole that we think should
be changed right now uh there are a
number of people in the country who can
choose in which jurisdiction to pay
their taxes uh by virtually you're
paying a fee that's not an option that's
available to most of my constituents and
if we closed it we could raise we
estimate over 3 billion pounds a year
that could be used for things like
training and recruiting more staff are
hard-pressed NHS this is a loophole
that's 200 years old that other
countries don't have yeah but Mrs sunac
is not a member of the government is she
she's not a member of the government but
the non-dom loophole should be closed
and if it was closed we could have more
money for our Public Services that's a
completely legitimate points to make uh
I believe we will keep up this campaign
yes what other areas are you looking at
well I don't know what's exactly coming
but we're going to continue to point out
the government's record we're going to
continue to camp in for the non-dome
loophole to be closed and we're going to
continue to point out that the country
can do better than simply a new Tory
prime minister every year so there's
nowhere that you won't go on the on
these um attack ads well look you judge
everything in the way that it comes but
we're certainly going I'm guessing his
kids are off limits we'll get we're
certainly going to keep campaigning on
the government's record and for example
uh the non-dong tax loophole is a
legitimate part of public debate because
it's something that we've said will
close in order to benefit our public
service
are you using an agency um to be honest
I'm not even sure by the way just on
this non-dom thing yeah we do this at
the time
when everyone else in the country has
seen their taxes go up this month uh
every one of your viewers is now going
to see their taxes go up in the coming
year because of the freezing personal
allowances most people will have seen
utility bills jump the 400 pounds a year
that they were getting with their energy
bills it goes away it's a pretty sharp
contrast okay to the loophole that
exists uh
and I accept that thank you very much
for dealing with that for me let me talk
to you about uni adopters going on
strike for four days and one of the
representatives from the BMA sat where
you were a little bit earlier on and
said she couldn't guarantee that lives
wouldn't be lost look I think that
strike is extremely worrying uh hundreds
of thousands of appointments procedures
and operations will not happen because
of it and that's in a service that's
already under huge pressure so I hope
that both sides do everything they can
to bring this to an end as quickly as
possible they can't they can't guarantee
that lives aren't at risk that their
whole ethos is to make sure that they
protect lives well it's extremely worry
and that our services there to protect
us is now you know under such pressure
and I don't think what's happening this
week is the result of uh something in
the short term I think it's been
building up for a long time and it's
really important that both the
government and the doctors
Representatives get around the table and
resolve this as quickly labor supports a
strike even if lives are at risk no we
don't we never say we support strikes
you know what we want to see is this
brought to an end as soon as possible
and there's a duty on everybody involved
to get around the table have the talks
get rid of all the preconditions that
have been stopping talks and make sure
that there aren't more strikes like this
after this week is over you're not
supporting the doctor strike I never see
we support strikes we regret uh it
strikes happen people have got a legal
right to do it but whenever there's a
strike it's actually a symptom of
failure it's a symptom that a normal
negotiating process hasn't worked so we
want to see this come to an end and in
the longer term it's not just about
their strike come and turn end we need
to do better with the NHS this is
imagine it came to an end tomorrow
you would still have seven million
people on the NHS waiting list what are
we going to do about that this is going
to take time to turn around we're going
to need the application and new
technology we're going to have to
recruit and train more staff in the
future we're going to have to have a
real National effort I'm going to get
this service because we are out back to
where it should be it's good to talk to
you as always